but now I present to you our
speaker born and educated in
Colombia Laura Mariño is an executive
with more than 20 years leading
product development teams and technology companies.
Her experience
spans large and small organizations
including
Microsoft
in a range of industries from
voice recognition  to
human resources
financial industry
recognized as an expert in
product management Laura has received several
pains and serves as an advisor to the founders
of saras and product leaders Laura
has two master's degrees from the university of
and is a lecturer in the
engineering department always teaching management
of product, she has also been a
lecturer at the Universidad los
Andes in Bogotá, a University of
California in Santa Bárbara, and in
business at the University of New York,
a promoter of women in technology.
Laura is a member of the board of directors
of Living Women in Technology, an
organization without  profit organization dedicated
to supporting the Advancement of women towards
Leadership positions, now I will
gladly pass you on to Laura. Thank you
very much Annette, it is a pleasure
to be here, it is a pleasure to have the
opportunity to talk about one of
my favorite topics, which is product management.
Today what we want is to talk a little
more about what product management is and
product management is a discipline
that has been developed a lot here in
technology companies but it is a
discipline that is still not very well
known outside the United States.
So  The objective of the seminar today
is to give you a clearer idea
of ​​what the role of the product manager is.
How it differs from more
traditional roles that exist in companies and
to end a little with the discussion of
why it is so important that this
discipline be  start learning more about
Latin America
But before starting I want to tell you
a little more about my story and how I
got to the job I am
currently doing Annette made a
very nice introduction but as
she mentioned, I am Colombian I
studied civil engineering at the
University of Los Angeles.  Andes in Bogotá and I
came to Stenfred to do a postgraduate degree in
civil engineering in the area of
hydraulic resources and for nine years I worked
with a former Stanford professor in a
consulting company developing
software for the management and operation of
reservoirs and water resources
But at the same time  At the end of those nine years, the
software industry was
exploding and I wanted to
change that industry. So what
I did was return to this industry and I did a
master's degree in
management engines, which is basically a
technical MVP, and that's where I started my
career in  I have been in the industry for
basically twenty years. I started as an
associate product manager and
worked in large and small companies.
I worked for many years in the
area of ​​voice recognition with Neans,
which was one of the first companies
that began to develop that technology
that is now  so well known I worked at
Microsoft at SAP and then later in
my career I started working as a
product executive leading the entire
product team in
technologies in areas from the
legal industry to the
human resources industry and more recently which
is a  financial technology company
that uses
Artificial Intelligence to improve
all
consumer debt resolution processes. And throughout
my career I have also been closely
linked to education.
I have been teaching classes in for
many years and one of the reasons why
What
asked me to start teaching about
product management is that when I
started my career in
product management there was not much information there
was no education about that
discipline it was something that was learned on
the job I was lucky that the
companies in  Where I initially entered, they
especially did not have a
very strong product management discipline and I
learned a lot in those first years,
but currently the demand for
product managers has increased, the
recognition that this is a
very important discipline has increased, and
currently there are many more
resources.  To learn this discipline,
universities have begun to teach
more courses on that discipline, both in
the courses within their
academic programs and in the case of online, there
is already a certification for product management,
as Anel mentioned. I also collaborate
with the University of Los Andes.
I have already taught two or three
summer sessions there on the importance of
product management and entrepreneurship and
I am also a
promoter of more women in technology
working in a non-
profit organization that tries to promote
leadership among women
and I want to talk a little about that  How are
we going to do this seminar in order to
understand what product management is, the
first thing is to understand a little what a
product is and also why
technology companies fail with it, then
we can move on to talk more about what the
role of a product manager is to talk about.  a
little about the history of how
the discipline of product management developed
and finally talk a little about what is
happening right now in Latin America,
we start first with What is a product? It
could be considered a
somewhat silly question. But the truth is that
understanding  What a product is and what a
product means varies a lot depending on the
situation and the type of industry,
so the most general way that
seems to me to define what a product is, a
product is something that creates
specific value for a group of people who
are clients or users.  and for the
organization that develops and distributes
that product, if we look at what is the type
of value that can be offered to
customers and users, it can be a value
like solving a problem if one is a
company and needs a product for
security to prevent them from  do
hacking one can buy a
security software product it is solving
a problem that the company has
another type of value could be providing
a benefit or satisfying a desire if
we think about Netflix for example
the benefit that Netflix is ​​giving
to users  It is to satisfy the desire
for entertainment and there are also
products that can facilitate a
job or a task something that is being
done but that can be made easier one
thinks with things like Powers and now
more recently
that is being used to facilitate and
speed up work  o things that
people or companies do
in terms of value to
the organization that is developing and
distributing the product the product
can generate direct income
products that are sold to people or
companies generate direct income
but the product can also help
sell another product or service many
of the products that are products for
consumers that are free for the
consumer the income for the
organization comes from advertising to be
able to sell thanks to the success that
the product has with consumers the
income comes because the people who want
Advertising wants to have access to
those consumers and there are also
internal products in large companies.
Many times internal products are built
to increase
productivity or reduce the company's costs.
And if you think about the types of
products, there are obviously very different types of
products.  There are types of
physical products. Those are atypically
the consumer products that one can
buy in
a warehouse, you cannot buy through
Amazon and there are the
digital products obviously. That is where I want
to focus more and that is where we
are working more in the area.  of
product management but
digital products too They
come in a very wide variety there
are what were traditionally
software products and in
ancient times software products you
could not buy a box that had
Microsoft Word and you bought the
software and the software ran  On the
computer, that has changed a lot now
with the cloud, but there are still
companies that, for security reasons,
prefer to buy software and install it,
as they say, install
a product to manage the
company's cooperation. For example,
they prefer not to do it in the cloud.  For
security fears, obviously software,
Software products that live in the
cloud that one does not have to download to their
computer and that are receiving
updates quickly is what
has grown the most in recent years,
but
apart from what the
software products themselves are.  One of the areas that
has grown the most and that brings the most interest and
complexity are digital products
that are really a combination of an
experience or a service that is
being facilitated through technology
but that is an access to a service that
the service itself can  that is not
digital and We have many examples of that,
everyone knows about Uber. Actually, the
service that Uber provides is access to
people who help you to
take you to the place where you need,
however, Uber is a
technology company and the product  technological that
they created is what has allowed the
realization of This market where there are
people providing the service people
needing the service if one thinks about
a number of the new products in
the part of the financial services
for those who are in Latin America
Obviously  everyone has heard of
nubac nubank is a financial company
but it is really a
technology company they started as a
technology company first but
it was offering the
financial services that were traditionally
offered by the banks where you went and
opened your savings account or followed your
credit card then increasingly
this combination of services and
products that are not digital but that
are being facilitated through
digital platforms This is an area
that has grown a lot and has finally become
clear. There are hybrid products if you
think about products like the iwatch, I think about it.
I have that it is a physical product but it
depends on quantities, the value of the product
depends a lot on the Software that runs
in the product and that allows the
capabilities that one looks for
on the other hand when I gave this I gave a
talk similar to this one at the University
of Los Andes ago  a few months I
asked the participants to
give me examples of what type of
digital products they were thinking about and as you see,
the answers here are all that
range from the more
traditional products like Office 35 which is a
product for productivity to things like
nequique and  MercadoLibre MercadoLibre is
an ecommerce in Latin America So
we have this whole range of products and
Why is it important to understand that the
range of products is very wide when
one works in product management one
has to be clearly clear about what
the product one is serving is and if
that product has components that go
beyond the purely technological component
another way of classifying products
It is according to the type of client there are
products for consumers we all
know each other Instagram Facebook there are
products for businesses
companies that sell software or
services that are important for
companies
there are products  and These are very
interesting where the user is the
consumer but the client is really
a business that is what they are
business
the company where she has been working
as a product executive is a
our clients are very
large financial companies banks credit card companies
who give us their
delinquent debts so that we
can work with those consumers who
have delinquent debts to collect
those debts using
digital systems using a very approach to
help the consumer And using
Artificial Intelligence But then
the users are very much those consumers
but the client to whom  We are
serving large
financial companies, there are also companies
that have service for both the
consumer and the client. If
you think of companies. For
example, zoom, zoom, one was an
individual consumer, one can use zoom, but
entire companies also use it and
there are marketplaces like  Uber and
internal products and also if one
considers the type of product there
is also differentiation according to the
industry that the product is serving.
What is interesting is that
this list continues to increase every day. It is
no longer available. It was not considered as
a category 12 years ago.  years but now it
is one of the largest categories in
Latin America fintec has increased
a lot
and Commerce has existed for a long
time but in the health area
but now new things for example there is already
talk of
protect they are companies that are
using software and technology  to
improve real estate processes and transactions
in Colombia Abby is one
of the companies that has received
venture investment to create a
solution in that space. There are also
companies that are applying technology
to revolutionize how the
insurance part is handled, for example, then it
that the main message is that
technology is opening the opportunity to
revisit how many of
the traditional industries that exist work
and when one is working on those
technological products that are
revolutionizing those industries
it is very important to understand what
that product consists of.
Now let's talk a little about  Why
technology companies fail, as we said,
there are lots of opportunities and here it
is no longer just everywhere,
a number of new company ideas are emerging.
Entrepreneurship has
increased in Latin America, in Europe, in the
United States, but as we know,
many
technology companies fail.  and Siri insights is
a group of analysts here in the Valley
who are dedicated to analyzing the
technology area and the
technology industry and they regularly do
research and do a post-mortem of
Starbucks companies that failed,
interview the founders and try to
understand which  are the
main reasons why a
technology company failed and as you
can see in these answers
six of the most common reasons why they
fail are related to a
failure in the product,
reason number two and until recently it
was reason number  one is
Non-marketing and one of the
interviews with one of the companies that
failed a few months ago was very
interesting what the
entrepreneur said the founder said we
did a number of things
correctly
but we ignored the most important thing
to look for and that is  focus on creating the
right product.
So
that leads us to think that one of the most
important things is this concept of What is
the right product? As I showed you
in the previous one, this idea is to attack
problems that are interesting to
solve instead of those that serve
a need.  in the market was cited
as a cause of failure in 35% of
cases. This is one of the characteristics
that has been seen a lot with
that they try to create a solution they
fall in love with the solution they create a
solution in search of a problem
or they find a  problem to solve
but they create the wrong product that is what
is known as not finding racc
marketing
is basic to building survive and
means that the company has been able
to find a good market that
has a real need and that it has been
able to develop  a product that
can satisfy that market
and one of the things that Mary Kaygan says
is one of the most well-known people
here, he has several books written on
product management and one of the things
that he says is that it doesn't matter how
good the team is.  of engineering that
one has in their company if they are not given
something worth building.
So the concept that you have to
create that you have to develop the
right product is very important, the
concept that sometimes when
entrepreneurs fall in love with a
solution  an idea that they had and they
have not validated it, they have not validated that it is an
idea that really solves a problem
in the market. That is a very common cause
of failures for product companies
and this is where the role of
product manager comes
precisely to avoid  For those types of
problems there has to be a person
who is looking at that, as Mary says,
also
behind every successful product there is
someone who led the product team
to combine technology and design
to solve real customer problems
in a way that meets the needs.
of the business and Here there are several
components that we are going to talk about in a little
more detail later but it is the
need to find solving
real problems in a way that
also serves the business so that the
company is viable
the product manager is the person who
lives at the intersection between
customer experience and needs, technology, and the
business itself and is charged with
making sure that the product
being built is something that
users and customers want to use; that
it is a product that can be built.  build
with the technology and capabilities that
the company has and that it is a product
that is viable from the business point of view
means that it is a
product that will allow the
company to maintain and grow and will not
ruin the company.  company
So if we look in a little more
detail What are the responsibilities
of the product manager at a high level,
the first is to define or discover the
right product at the right time
What does that mean to define identify
a product or a functionality that
has value for customers  that so
that those people are willing to
use them and pay for it that it can be
developed with the technology that exists
and that the market is ready to adopt
then here we are talking about the
technical feasibility and the many of the
products that failed a few years ago  years they
were products that were focused on
things when, for example,
three-dimensional television began, there were
companies that decided that that was going to
be the market and they began to develop
glasses to watch three-
dimensional television, the market was not ready and
they failed then the concept of defining
the right product at the
right time requires one to understand the
market
Once that has been done the next
role of the product manager is to guide and
ensure the development of that product
now the product manager does not
develop the product the
product manager works  with the
engineering group to develop the product
and a typical thing is that engineering does not
report to the product manager the
product manager is guiding them he is
directing what engineering should build
but without engineering
reporting to them the product manager  You
have to manage all this through
influence and by explaining why
then the next step is to deliver the
complete product to the market. The concept
of the complete product is very important,
as we saw a few minutes ago, the
product itself can be more than
just the technology part
and  Even though the product manager
may not be responsible for all
the other components and there is a
financial service component, the
product manager has to be
working collaboratively with the other
functions in the organization to
ensure that by the time they launch
a  product to the market that product
is really serving the
customer's needs. A serious mistake that
product managers make is to think that their
only responsibility is to ensure
that engineering has finished the development of the
software and they can throw it away. That
product will not be successful if it is not  has
looked at what is everything else that is
needed for customers to see the
value in that product
and finally the product manager
has to measure the results of that
product that was launched on the market And
define the evolution of the product a
product unless  fail totally it
is never finished in version the
products are constantly evolving and
the product manager in each iteration
has to be looking now at what
we learned What is next What is the
next need that we can help
fulfill with this product
if you look at this group of
responsibility are
very big responsibilities and the situation can be
different depending on the size of the
company on an Instagram typically the
founder the entrepreneur is the one who is
playing this role Maybe not what you do
n't know by the name of
product management but the entrepreneur  The
founder or co-founder of the company
is typically the one who is in charge of
all this happening now once it
starts to grow a mistake that
founders make is thinking that they can
continue doing this and at the same time
be in charge of growing sales and marketing and
all  the other things they have to
worry about So it is very important
when you start to have some of this
when the first product has already come out on the
market that the founders realize
that they have to now assign a
person a product manager who is in
charge of seeing which  It is the next
iteration of defining what the
next functionalities of the product are.
In large companies, there are surely
many products and there will be many
product managers, and in companies that
have complex products, there
is usually no product manager who has
this responsibility for the entire
product.  There are going to be groups of
product managers working on
specific areas of the product and having
responsibility for the evolution and
development of those areas. For example,
I have a fairly large team where
there is a group of
product managers who are very focused on the
of the product that interacts with
consumers and they are
constantly experimenting to see
how to improve interaction with
consumers How to make
consumers more
involved How are they going to
create their
payment plans There is another group that is
working with a  internal group in the
company we have a call center
when the maybe They have any
questions they have to call the center
because the call center agents have to
use the product to understand What
has happened with that consumer to
understand the whole story They have
their needs  I have a
product group that is working with them,
a product group that works with
these very large financial clients and
is looking at what reports they
need, what integration needs to be done
to bring in the data, each group has
an area of ​​responsibility, but
obviously everyone.  They have to work
together and I am responsible for looking at the
entire area. But then the concept
of product manager and these
responsibilities still exist even
when the product manager only
owns one area of ​​the product
as you can see it is a role that is
quite  big is quite important and that is
why there is a cliché that the
product manager is the president of the
product, the truth is that my opinion That
is not a very very clear description
because the product manager does not have
control over engineering he does not have
control over the  other areas only have
influence But there is also another thing that
is very important, the
product manager does have this very
important role of directing, I think more like
an orchestra director But he is also
the person responsible for ensuring that
anything that is being forgotten It doesn't matter
Whose responsibility the
product manager has to be on top of that and that is
why I say that it is also the
responsibility if there is something that no
other group is taking responsibility for
but it is necessary for the success of the
product in the market the
product manager  you must be able to Identify and either
take responsibility or find Which
group should take that responsibility
so I wanted to move on now to talk in
a little bit smaller more in detail
let's say What is the job of a
product manager during the
product development cycle in the program
that  offered
online there is a whole course that goes in
more detail through each of these stages
of product development discussing
What are the tools What is the
approach but it seems to me that it is to
give you a clearer idea of ​​the role that
a product manager plays.  product it is
important that we discuss what that
product development cycle is
and it is a very iterative cycle but
basically it starts with the discovery part
finding identifying that opportunity in
the market again if you are an
entrepreneur you are the entrepreneurs they are the ones who
are looking at them  What
is the opportunity in the market? If you
are a product manager who is
managing a product that already exists, what
you have to identify is what is the
next thing to do in the product
that is the most valuable, then you have to
evaluate if that  opportunity It is worth it
if it is worth investing those
engineers who are very valuable
in developing this
specific functionality, you have to validate you have to
validate if that need is
strong enough for
customers to want to use the solution and
then you have to design the solution
and  There is a lot of work that can be done
in the design and validation of the
solution before putting a lot of
engineering resources into building it. That
is one of the things that has
developed the most in recent years.
One's approach can be a lot of
experimentation.  one can do a lot of
validation in a way that is less
expensive before dedicating months of
software development to a product that
may not be successful so there are
all processes to design and
validate the design of the solution before
actually starting development
formal of the product Once
the development and delivery of the
product begins That is where the
product manager is working very
closely with engineering but
engineering is building the product
the product manager guides and is the
person who is representing What
the needs are  of the client but
engineering makes the technical decision of
how to build that product once
the product is built it is the
launch to the market and that is what I
told them about the importance of understanding
what the complete product is when I
was in if we worked in
recognition of  voice, we were
creating the fundamental technology
for voice recognition and the way
the technology was being used
at that time was for large companies
that wanted to automate
customer service, but this
voice recognition technology if
we gave it to a bank they  They
couldn't do anything with it, the product
itself needed other components to provide the value.
We worked with
companies that were partners, they incorporated
our technology into
systems that respond to
phone calls and then we had to
work with professional services
to design the application that would go.  to be
the building that was going to interact with
the person calling on the phone,
then depending on the product
one has, the complete product that
has to be delivered to the market can be
more or less complex and the
product manager, especially in those companies
with technology  more complex it has to
be working very closely with
the other departments that have to
have the ability to help bring
that product to the market
once the product is brought to the
market we have to start measuring it if it is
the first version of the product we have to
have  a lot of understanding what
customers are saying if they are
being successful or not What is the
information one should
get data as much as possible there are already many
technologies And many methodologies
to measure each thing companies that
are in e-commerce have the ability to
measure exactly  What the consumer did
at each step and optimize with respect to
that. For example, we had the
ability to follow Juan if a
consumer had opened the email that we
had sent him. What he had done next,
and based on that, our
Artificial Intelligence could make
decisions.  following How
to communicate with that consumer but to
obtain that data and then be able
to experience what happens if we try something
different becomes very important for
the evolution of the product and as I
said, a product, unless it fails
completely, will have many iterations,
the product will  As it grows, there will be new
functionality and the product manager
has to be making that decision. What
is the most important thing for the next
version of the product?
With that, I think I have given you, let's say, a fairly
quick and fairly
compressed summary of What is
product management?  When I started
my first experience as a
product manager, there were not many places
where one could learn and there were not
many of the tools that
currently exist, but to give you an
idea of ​​how this has grown almost as
an industry, there are already companies.  of
technology that are designing products
to help the work of
product management and there are many companies that
focus on helping
product managers create that
path the path the product map
forward there are companies that help product
managers  products to take those
measurements to be able to understand what is
happening with the product once that
product goes on the market to be able to put
all the instrumentation within the
product that allows the
product manager to really know what is
happening and based on that to make
decisions.  to rehearse for the
next version of the product
but taking, let's say, a step back
to a higher level What is the
product manager doing the
product manager is actually managing
risks What risks is he managing
value risk
is he managing value risk  If
customers are going to want to buy and use the
product and that is why what I
told them regarding
the initial validation of the
opportunity is so important,
historically there have been cases of
companies that had an idea and
dedicated themselves to making the product, launching
a  product the following year and
they discovered that no one was interested in
that product and those companies went bankrupt. We
have clearly learned that this
validation of whether customers are going to
want to use the product has to
be done continuously before
making a large investment
in creating and  build that product the
second risk is the
business viability risk It is not only
important that customers and
users want to use the product that
product and growing that product has to
do in a way that is viable for
the business so that the company  don't
break
then
that business viability is included
in the way
product managers have to think about their
product is not only whether
customers will like the product but whether the
product can be made within the
constraints of
engineering budget if it is a product that
people are going to pay for it and
additionally there are another series of
restrictions that are very important to
take into account if one is working
in
regulated industries if one is working in
fintech in the financial part if one
is  working in the health part, the
regulations and regulations may
vary from country to country from state to state
but it is something very very important to take
into account because the products
have to follow these regulations and
it is the responsibility of the
product manager to work  with the experts in
the legal part to ensure that the
product that goes on the market is a
product that complies with the
regulations
the risk of technical feasibility
the product must be able to be built
with the technology that exists and with the
capabilities that exist in the company  It
is not very logical that a company that
has engineers who have dedicated their entire lives
to being, let's say,
mobile applications, that one moment the
company decided that we are going to
become experts completely in
Artificial Intelligence and we are going to put
our engineering group  to
make a whole new model of
Artificial Intelligence in that case it
would be necessary to recreate the engineering group.
So it is very important to understand what
is possible with the technology that exists
and if you want to If you want to do something
that is very different from what is possible with
the  engineering group or if it is necessary to
bring a whole new capacity to
create the product
and there is the risk of usability, be
sure that the users
will want to use the product and that is a very
important part, which is the work of the
design team.  design team
normally and in the companies
where I have worked lately the
design group is part of the
product team the product team has
the product managers and the
designers and it is very important because
one of the things that has happened
especially when you are in b2b in the
old years a lot of the Software that
companies used had a
terrible user experience but that did
not matter much to them because really
the company that the person in the
company who made the decision to
buy the product was taking  the
decision was based on whether the product had
the necessary functionality, if it had,
it handled the complexity that
the company needed, but if you think about what
products like Oracle and that IP
were like years ago, the user experience was really
secondary, but what has happened is
that in the  As there have been more and
more products on the market for
consumers and people who work in
companies also use very well
designed products for consumers, the demand
for good user experience even in
products that are dedicated to companies
has grown a lot and that has  A fact that
has become much more important even in
products that are sold to companies
is to be sure that users will
want to use the product because a
company can make an investment in a
state product and can try to
force its employees to use it.  If the
employees do not like that product,
possibly that product is not going to be
successful within that company, which
means that the following year the
company will not invest. So it is
very important that those
who are going to be the ones who use the product
they want to use the product they find it
intuitive they find it easy to use and
in this
the product manager works very collaboratively with the
design people and finally one thing that has
become increasingly important is the
ethical risk the product manager
obviously  This does not fall solely on the
shoulders of the product manager. That is
part of the values ​​of the
joint company but the fact that something
can be developed and created does not
necessarily mean that it should
and now there are a number of questions
about what they are.  ethical things and things that are
unethical And yet Before talking about the
whole discussion about
there are And how to use it or not, even before that there
are things that in certain products
use, let's call it that way, tricks to
get consumers to do something
that perhaps is not  In their best interest,
that is what they are called in English, they call them darks. It
is like a trick to let's say that they
trick the consumer into
doing something just to increase the use of the
product. So the
product manager must have an ethical level to
say what it is.  my goal is to serve
this consumer or this client and I am
developing something in the product that is
just a gimmick to achieve a
result that I want to see or is it
really something that is helping
advance the needs of that
consumer
I am seeing some questions in the
I think the chat is great. Let's go a
little faster because I want us to
have time for questions, but in
summary, the responsibility of the
product manager is to combine technology and design
to solve real
customer problems, satisfying the needs
of the business, and I
already see a question from  Manuela here
first and I'm going to answer her when I
say it is the responsibility of the
product manager. No, the truth is that and
especially in larger companies or
companies with several products or with
complex products. This is the
responsibility of the product team,
a team.  A complex product needs
many product managers. Each
product manager will have responsibility
for an area of ​​the product and within that
area they have to be thinking about the
same things. What is most important.
Where is the value that I can
add in this area.  of the product and
What is the problem? It is solving one of
the most important characteristics of what
product managers have to do is to always make difficult decisions
no matter where you work there
will always be more ideas and more
requests than engineering can do.
There are never enough
engineering resources to do everything
that all the people have ideas or
what all the customers ask for. The
product manager has to be able to look at
all those ideas. Look at everything that
customers are asking. Understand
the market and  say what is most
important where to focus those
engineering resources to produce the
maximum value and again There is an
entire product team that is going to be
in charge of that responsibility at the
most global level but at the most micro level in the
specific product area  The
product manager has to be looking at those
details,
as I tell you, that is a
very big responsibility and obviously the
product manager cannot work alone. A
group that is very important has to
work very united. It is what I call the
product triumvirate of products.  They are
the product manager working with the
designer and with the leader typically and
the organization of current companies
normally a product manager is
working with a designer and with an
engineer who are working in an
area of ​​the product in very
small companies it is all the  product when a
company is just starting Well, the
entire group is working on the
first version of the product but when
there are already several products or the
products are complex, the distribution
is done by product areas and
normally this group of three people
has to work very  United why the
product manager is the one who has to
be looking at all the requirements
all the opportunities and making an
idea of ​​all the things that could be
engineering Which are the most
important but for that he also has to
be consulting with the
technical leader to  understand what is possible with
technology and how complicated it is
because there may be ideas that require
a lot of engineering. Ah, there may be
ideas that are things that are easier to do
and even though the Total value is not so
important, they are something very easy to do
that type of thing.  conversations have to be
had with the leader and in terms of validating
that opportunity that the
product manager has and really finding
What is the solution for the need
working with the designer is key and that
has to be done from the beginning
in the old times when I  I started
working with that one, for example, it was
very common for product managers
to decide that it was the functionality that
was needed and work with
engineering to create it and in the end
they brought in a designer to try to
make that functionality more
accessible to the user but  that is not the
focus now the focus is the
designers working
closely with the product manager
have to help design that solution
from the beginning I
wanted
especially in Latin America what I have
seen in large companies what happens
in large companies in companies for
For example, large companies that
are now going through the
digital transformation process, these companies
are beginning to create
digital products for the services they had, whether it
be an airline or a bank, but
many of these companies do not have the
concept of Urgent product and they
normally do.  They can be confused with a
project manager and they are two
very different roles. A project manager is
a person who is responsible for
ensuring that a project is executed
according to the scope, budget and
time established.
the scope of the
project such as the time we have to
do it and the cost we have and is the
person who is in charge of ensuring that
those things are accomplished and normally a
project manager is assigned to a
specific project for a
limited time and moves on to the next project.  The
product manager is responsible for
identifying problems worth
solving, prioritizing what needs to be
done and how to do it, and is responsible for the
result.
The product manager
is expected to be more and more in product companies.  that
shows results that shows
results in time in terms of, for
example, adoption of the product, then it
is not simply saying we have already finished and
delivered the product on time. That
is not the expected result and a
product manager is dedicated to the
same product in the long term.  then
he delivers a new functionality And
then he has to be thinking about what is the
next thing we are going to do, which is the
next area where I have to
focus the engineering group
working on my product area
So they both lead
multidisciplinary groups through influence
but they are  two different roles now the
product manager sometimes has to
play a little bit of the role of
project manager and It is good to have those
capabilities but they are two very
different roles there is another role known
as the Owner it is a role within the
model there is and  It is a very specific role
in charge of managing the but it is a
much smaller role than the role of
product manager. Many times the
product manager has to play the
role of Prague but they are not the same. The
product manager is a much
larger role.  that then as a summary
a product manager really has
to be successful has to have a
very deep knowledge of the
customers and the users of the data
that is being received about the
adoption of the product of the industry in
which it is mainly  If it is a
regulated business and product industry and
that takes months, on the other hand, that does not
mean that the product manager
has to be the expert in everything,
but the product manager has to be
able to work very closely with the
other groups at the same time.  legal group to the
business group to understand that industry and
be able to bring a product to the market that
is successful
quickly a little bit the history of
product management the truth is the
history of product management
goes back to the 1930s where a
person, an executive
Dembow my  Alma decided that she needed to
create a new role, which was the
brand managers and defined them as
people who were totally responsible for the
success of a brand and that brand, those
people had to decide the
promotion part of the product, the price of the product, the
packaging of the product, but
also  He was a professor and he
greatly influenced two entrepreneurs who
were and when they started the
company they took that concept from
that brand manager and translated it into
a person who would really be the voice
of the customer within the
product development process
and initially  The product managers
and brand managers lived, let's say,
within the marketing group, but
once technology and
new technology companies started and they were
developing totally
new products, it was not possible to wait until
the product was ready and then
put the people in charge.  product managers do
about marketing then
the technologies of
modern technology companies began to bring
the product manager much more
linked to the development of the
product itself so that the voice of the
consumer The Voice of the customer was
present from the moment it was  I
was defining the product and with the
advent of things like ayaal and link,
which has changed, let's say
product development has become much more
agile, much more iterative and the relationship
between product management and
engineering has become closer, the
role of product manager has become closer.  It has received even
more importance in
technology companies and when I started my career
I worked in product management, I was
part of the marketing group, but
for years now
technology companies have realized that it is
such an important role that it has to be
a  separate marketing and
engineering department to make the balance is
the group that is making those
very difficult decisions of what to do
how to prioritize
the engineering work to
better serve the market And currently if
you look at What the Organization is like in
modern software companies  There is a
product group that reports
directly to the president, it is separate
from Marketing and engineering, and within
engineering there is a clear separation of
What is product engineering, the
engineering group that is
developing the product for
external customers, and what is it.  which is
traditionally you for the
internal functioning of the company,
so I wanted to just move on to a
very short comment about why this
is, in my opinion, becoming
increasingly important in Latin America and it is
because the level of entrepreneurship, the
level of digital transformation and  The
level of risk investment in
Latin America has increased greatly.
These are data from a lagba company
that is in charge of checking
capital investment in Latin America, but based
on this data, in 2021 there were 15.9
billion dollars in
risk investment in Latin America in  Two because there
has been a fairly large drop in
the market. The investment was seven
point eight billion dollars in
Latin America, but it is still the second
largest number in the history of
risk investment in Latin America in
terms of the number of days.  The number of
rounds that were funded
in 2021 was 915, in
2022 there were more than 1,000. What does that
mean that there is now a lot more
investment going to
new technology companies that are creating
technology products or services that
are facilitated by  technology
most of the investment 77 between
77 and 80 percent of this investment has
gone to Brazil Mexico and Colombia And of course
there are some
companies that everyone knows
nubank is possibly the best known
fast in Colombia they have had are
unicorns they have had  some
huge investments but those same companies
are now creating their own
investment ecosystem people who worked at
rappi are now going out and creating
new companies. So let's say that
ecosystem that existed so long that it
had been so difficult to reproduce
is beginning to emerge in Latin America
and therefore  That is so important that
Latin America begins to know how they
work and what roles are important
so that these new
technology companies have a greater chance of success.
And again, I believe what I have seen is
that there are two very different approaches: there are
traditional companies.  that they are being
forced to have a
digital transformation but those were companies in
which the objective of technology is to
serve the business and the approach has been they
have a group of you and they ask you to
make an application, yet those companies
are realizing that to  be
competitive and taboo want to buy
compete against no and it is not nubank is a
company that was a native digital company
they were born as a
technology company that was going to transform
access to financial services in
Latin America
that gives them a very big advantage
traditional companies of
financial services have to start providing
all the digital systems is something
different but even in those
large companies. Even if some of those who are
listening to this presentation work in
large companies that are doing
digital transformation, that concept of
that product management role is very
important and one of the problems that
these traditional companies have is
that this concept does not exist, so it
has never existed as a person or a
group of people who are responsible
for that nexus between what the
client and the consumer want, what
technology can do.  and what the
business wants and normally what happens is that
there are groups groups that there are part of people the
business people are saying something
engineering has a project manager
who is telling them to deliver but
that concept that there is a person a
responsible group does not  exists and I think it
is important that it begins to exist here
in the United States those companies
are already bringing the product heritage
inside also
to finish
just so that you remember a
main cause of case of
technology companies is not creating a
correct product and management of  product combines
technology, business and
customer needs to
increase the probability of success of
those technology companies,
both entrepreneurs and
technology companies that are growing, as well as
established companies that want to
innovate, have to incorporate that
discipline and digital transformation and
change  in the venture investment landscape
in Latin America they create a
very large demand for these product managers
and with that I think I don't know if we have
time for questions I would love to I
have time for questions but I don't know
if we have time for questions or we
can answer them  Synchronously,
we have a minute for a question from
Cristian
who accompanies us from Salvador, who says as a
product manager What tools
can help me decide This is the
right product,
there are tools But to be
honest there is no
magic tool to decide What is the product
with  the right product the most valuable thing
is to talk to customers understand getting under
the feet of users and
customers to understand what
they need to understand what their
problem is. So there are
design strategies in and there are
books that talk about how to make that
discovery  strategies on how to do
that user discovery How to
do that customer discovery
but there is no tool that
simply tells you This is the solution
and These are part of the things that one
can begin to cover more in the
more advanced product management courses
Is there a way we can at
least have this this list of questions
and see if they can be answered
asynchronously there is not that much there is not that
many there is just one one more
says we are a group of engineers
with desires to we tend to have a more
focused on  consultancies as resources
as resources we can use to change
our our minser become more
product-oriented
How there is a lot right now there are
many more books and information
about What is product heritage How
to focus But one of the most
important steps of moving from consulting to
product is consultancies are focused
on serving a specific client and
developing
the measure the step to product requires
beginning to understand in a more
generalized way the problem that the
industry has or the problem that that
group of clients has that one is
trying to serve  because it is very
different to develop a product to
serve a specific client that has
all the requirements of that client
from a product that is going to be successful in
the market that many companies or
many people are going to use. And
then the main tool is not to
focus  only in talking to that
client and the requirements of that
client but rather going to the market and validating that
those requirements are also had by
other clients or understanding more clearly
the most general requirements of the
market,
thank you Well, that was the last
question
and the time
I was going  to comment that since it exists online, it
now has the courses in
product management, the number of courses is increasing.
And that is an opportunity to
start going into more detail in
some of the things that I covered
can begin to be covered in more detail
in  those courses
Yes and if you are interested in learning more
about
product management and these visit our website
Online
to find more information and thank you
again for joining us you will receive the
a link to this recording in a week or two
and I hope that everyone has
Found this webinar
useful for you and
better understand the role of the product manager
Thank you all Thank you very much